hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll
you might know if you follow the physics
news that Jim hartle passed away
recently Jim was a wonderful theoretical
physicist a founder of quantum cosmology
frequent collaborator with Stephen
Hawking Murray Gelman people like that
he was also one of the collaborators
with Thomas hertog our recent mindscape
guest on the wave function of the
universe again with Stephen Hawking what
you could predict how things came out
and so forth and he passed away recently
it was very sad uh Jim had a important
role in my life he hired me for my
second postdoc and always struck me as
someone who was a very deep thinker very
careful but with a puckish sense of
humor that made him very fun to be
around so I was being interviewed by a
reporter from physics today for the
write-up they were going to do the
obituary if you want to call it that on
Jim's passing and he mentioned that he
was talking to Thomas hertog before and
we were talking about the relationship
the reporter and I were talking about
the relationship of physics and
philosophy Jim was sort of pro
philosophy but he wasn't into it right
like he thought it was a good thing but
he wasn't himself reading a lot of
philosophers or anything like that so
apparently the reporter had also asked
Tomas about it and Tomas had related the
story that he and Stephen and Jim had
written a paper which I think was called
Eternal inflation without metaphysics
metaphysics you know a word borrowed
from philosophy and Tomas explained to
the reporter that the editor of the
journal made them remove the word
metaphysics from the title because he
didn't think it was appropriate so this
was my opportunity to reveal a little
secret here it was not the editor of the
journal who objected to that use of the
word it was the referee and the referee
was me I was refereeing their paper and
I thought they misused the word
metaphysics they had to find it in the
paper as parts of the theory that are
not observable that make no difference
to the observable predictions I get why
they would say that but there's more to
metaphysics than that I think that
people in different academic disciplines
should play nicely with each other and
respect each other's terminology but I
get it I get why people have this
misapprehension about what metaphysics
is if you go to a bookstore and go to
the metaphysics section good luck to you
there's a whole bunch of things about
crystals and auras and new agey stuff
and and things like that I think that
people out there don't really know what
metaphysics is you've come to the right
place if this is uh that description
includes you Katie Elliott is a
philosopher metaphysician they call a
metaphysicians not metaphysicists so
we're going to learn Katie was nice
enough to agree to rather than focus in
on one of her particular research
problems which would have been very
interesting we basically are trying to
give an overview here we're going to
work up to some questions that she does
research on about time travel about
possible worlds about what a cause is
what an explanation is things like that
that's what Katie does for a living but
we're going to build up there gradually
by giving an overview of what
metaphysics is why the idea of
metaphysics might be useful is it just
replaced by physics no it's talking
about things that are supposedly even
more fundamental than physics right The
Logical structure of possible physical
realities in addition to our actual
physical reality and I hope that you
come away with the impression that
metaphysics is actually useful that
metaphysics plays a role and it's not
just talk about unobservable things that
have no consequences so let's go
[Music]
thank you
Katie Elliott welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you so much it is really
exciting slash terrifying to be here the
terrifying weird had to work on that I
want to terrify more of my guests I
think that too many of them are
complacent so I'm glad you're starting
terrified
yeah when you at the beginning we were
chatting and you were like you're really
dumb and this is going to expose this to
the world I thought that part was I
gotta do more of that right yeah there's
more of that yeah you know I just
recently started for our patreon
listeners I started doing like a little
couple minute video afterward uh just
saying hey you know that was fun here's
what I learned whatever but I gotta
start spreading the rumor that what I'm
really saying is geez what an idiot
exactly here's where I wrote just from
patreon observe uh supporters yeah
anyway so let's start
let's warm up with something easy what
is metaphysics
that's not easy
um great question I feel like that's the
kind of question where you could ask a
bunch of different philosophers and get
a lot of different answers but the sort
of like stock things that people will
say
um is that metaphysics is something like
the study of what there is or a study of
what there is I suppose there are many
different studies of what there is but
metaphysics is one of the studies of
what there is
or maybe metaphysics is also interested
in
um relationships of fundamentality and a
kind of proprietary sense of
fundamentality
um so that's that's very big picture
then you might think well look
um you know science is the study of what
there is
um and that's true
um so maybe metaphysics is something
like the unrestricted study of what
there is or really trying to get the the
full story about the whole kitten
caboodle and not just pockets of it so
maybe the more specific version of the
question is how do you conceive of the
relationship between metaphysics and
physics my understanding is that the
name metaphysics got stuck just because
it's the book Aristotle wrote after he
wrote the book the physics that's my
understanding too I mean so I have how I
like to think of the relationship
between
science physics and the kind of inquiry
um that I do I think that again
different philosophers will give you
different stories about like what the
relationship is
but for me the I think of myself as a
metaphysician because ultimately the
kinds of questions I'm interested in are
about what kinds of things exist
and what they're like but the
methodology that I'm committed to is
that sort of the the ideas that the main
way we're going to figure out
interesting stuff about what the world
is like is by studying the success of
scientific inquiry or maybe the success
of a particular instance of scientific
inquiry say the history of physics or
something so we're going to look at this
discipline both its content what it says
the world is like but also what it does
and how it works and that's going to
tell us a lot about what the world we
live in is like
um and one way of seeing that is that if
you take for granted that science is
successful then you might ask yourself
like what are the preconditions for the
success of science what does our world
have to be like in order for this kind
of intellectual discipline to be as
successful as it's been and some of us
though not all of us but some of us
think the world would have to be quite
particular in various ways uh it would
have to be law governed there would have
to be things like causes maybe there
would have to be things like chances so
there have to be these certain
metaphysical ingredients in the world
in order for science to proceed as it
does at the rate of success that it does
and so science the success of science is
going to tell us something about these
metaphysical posits okay so that's a
little bit different than I would have
guessed I mean trying to of course we
can just disparage metaphysics or any
other phys any other field if we want to
but I I figured that maybe a friendly
physics versus metaphysics distinction
would be that metaphysics thinks about
sort of the logically necessary aspects
of how the world is and physics thinks
about the more contingent aspects like
these are the actual laws versus the
idea of laws
yeah totally so uh metaphysics is an
enormously broad project and the kinds
of questions that I'm interested in
might best be like
subtitled metaphysics of science or
something
but it is true that the sort of main
methodological tools we have as
metaphysicians is just what happens and
then like thinking about it hard and uh
thinking about it hard stuff is
presumably invokes all kinds of logical
principles all kinds of reasoning
principles maybe some stronger claims
about what we could a priori know to be
true about the world just by thinking
about it hard but I mean to be clear
there are lots of metaphysicians that
are just as you say interested in
non-contingent things so maybe they're
interested in the nature of numbers or
doing metaphysics of logic or trying to
understand the relationship between a
table and its microconstituent parts or
I mean you you name it we can what's
what's God like what's truth like yeah
you can go lots of questions I'm glad
we're gonna answer them in the remaining
you know we're going to start with
what's got like good work up to what are
numbers let's begin and maybe again just
for the audience that is not tuned into
this spending their spare time reading
metaphysics books how do you contrast
that with similar sounding words like
ontology and epistemology
yeah great I think of ontology as a
thing metaphysicians are interested in
so I guess I think one you know
Anthology is sort of like the collection
of things that you believe in the stuff
uh stuff you believe in so if you're an
atheist god is not a neurontology if
you're a theist God is in your ontology
you're a deist or something so it's like
the big bucket of stuff you believe in
um and then uh one metaphysical project
is to try to give you know the ontology
of existence the maybe the fundamental
ontology of existence So what at the
most fundamental level are the things
that there are that are real
um and we get very spicy about that it's
not like our dragons real or something
you know it's like our extended symbols
real you know it's these sort of
abstract ideas that does the world come
with this kind of stuff
and then epistemology is something like
the study of how we come to know about
the world and
uh yeah ticket it means something like
theory of knowledge but just very
broadly it's questions about how we know
stuff what we know how we know it how we
should reason about the evidence we have
I would like you to tell me whether
extended symbols are real and first what
I don't know first tell me what an
extended simple at USC you should have
her on the podcast she'll talk to you
about extended simple how about what an
extended simple is supposed to be I like
so I like just that throwing out the
jargon there because it gives us a
little glimpse into the way you're
actually thinking about it not when
you're just dumbing it down for us yeah
fair enough so um a simple is an object
that has no parts
um and an extended object is just an
object that's extended in space-time
and so the question is could there be
something partless that's extended in
space-time I think that's the question
anyway that's truly the answer is I
don't know but surely it kind of sounds
like a physics question doesn't it or is
the metaphysics coming in when we're
deciding you know not just the
instrumental things that physicists like
to talk about you know invoking things
to make predictions but the harder
questions of which parts of these are
real and actual
I mean this is kind of interesting maybe
you don't think of things in this way
but how does tell me if this resonates
with you
so like certainly not every
metaphysician would think this but I
think a relatively common thought is
something like look um we could ask
questions just about what are coherent
pictures of what the world is like what
are you know science doesn't sort of
start from an infinite set of options
um whether we start from a highly
constrained conceptual framework about
General we have General background
assumptions about what the world is like
and what kinds of things we should even
be looking for or could coherently look
for and the physicist is going to start
their project from an enormous amount of
background assumptions quite substantive
background assumptions about what kinds
of things they could even really be
looking for there's a lot of options
that just sort of aren't on the table
and maybe the metaphysician is trying to
think okay for real in the in the
biggest sense possible what are the
options on the table
um so like what kinds of objects even
coherently make sense uh what kinds of
things could you even try to build try
to use an anthology of a theory of what
the world is like so like uh you know
our souls on the table that used to be a
big question
um and so the question about extended
simples I take it is is not the question
of like are there any extended symbols
though that would be an interesting
important question but just do these
things make sense and if they make sense
how would they behave and if we know how
to think of them could positing them do
any work in some of these cases where
we're trying to understand what's going
on at the base level so maybe the
metaphysician is trying to pick out like
conceptually coherent Frameworks for
some kind of scientific inquiry to even
sort of take place in how much do the
best modern meta Physicians it always
makes me sad they're not called
metaphysicists but I've learned to make
my piece with that how much do they
think about modern physics in terms of
just the basics of quantum mechanics and
relativity and so forth
yeah I think there's a huge amount of
variation so I think it the Gambit runs
with contemporary successful
metaphysicians all the way from like not
at all
to like oh my work is highly constrained
by the results and I need to be on The
Cutting Edge of
um advancements in say quantum mechanics
uh to figure out like what The Cutting
Edge Story of what the world is like
um so there's a huge range and the range
isn't sort of random it's um I take it
it's reflected in the kinds of questions
that the particular metaphysician is
interested in
um so some questions it seems like no
matter how the physics shakes out we're
gonna have to figure out I don't know
what numbers are like or what truth is
um and then other questions and seems
like how the physics is going to shake
out might make a big difference
um like is the world deterministic or
something or what is space and things
like that or what a space yeah good good
so yeah let's see let's get a little bit
more specific because you did a great
job of telling us the basic project but
there's all sorts of delicious specific
questions that we'll never have time to
get to all of them but as I mentioned
before we started I was recently
um tricked into writing a short piece
about something called the principle of
sufficient reason uh giving the
physicist view on this I mean I could
have made it very short by saying most
physicists have no idea what the
principles fish reason is but I I went a
little bit further than that so why
don't you tell us what it is is this and
is it something that the modern
metaphysician
believes in keeps in mind thinks about
um great so
um let me try to uh Bluff my way through
this part
um principle of sufficient reason uh I
don't know much about the history but I
take it it's something like this
something like the thought that look you
just sit back and like kind of think
about how things work uh and you think
about them real hard you think like well
here's here's gotta be the way things
work
um everything that happens there's got
to be some story about why it happened
um I'm not sure how to fill in this
premise I'm not sure how to tell you why
you should think that for everything
that happens there's got to be some
story about why things happen but we can
think about that but suppose I got you
on board with the thought that like look
if everything that happens uh there's
some reason why it happens maybe you
come to that conclusion just by looking
at the world around you and say get well
for many things there's a reason why it
happens and I think that's the general
way or maybe you've got some kind of
religious background and principles that
make you think this
um and then the thought is look for
everything that happens there's not just
sort of a reason why it happens but
there's some reasons you would give such
that given those reasons the uh event
that we were initially trying to give a
reason for had to occur so for
everything that happens there's a
certain sense at which it had to happen
there were some background reasons or
background conditions that were
sufficient for bringing about the thing
that we began with and I think this I
think historically the power of this
principle has been as a kind of a priori
principle that was supposed to sort of
guide methodology so you know when
you're looking at the world and trying
to organize it in a way that makes sense
to you one of the things you can have in
your back pocket is that well whatever's
happening you're going to be able to
find some other thing that was
sufficient for it and you could see how
that would sort of guide your
exploration of the world
and I think clearly quantum mechanics is
going to mess with this a little bit but
even back in the classical world in the
you know laplace's demon kind of world
the physicist would joke and say yeah
there's a reason for everything namely
the laws of physics and the initial
conditions for the universe those are
the reasons why everything happens but
maybe that that's a hilarious physics
joke
we abuse ourselves isn't that what is
most important
uh but is that what one might have in
mind I mean it's certainly not what we
invoke in our everyday life when we say
oh the reason why I did this is the laws
of physics plus the initial conditions
of the Big Bang like we try to be a
little bit more local and macroscopic
than that yeah I mean so um I mean maybe
one of the things that's interesting
about metaphysics as opposed to physics
or something is that a lot of the
problems or questions that we're working
on
um you can arrive at with a very thin
understanding of what the actual details
are so if you had something like the
principle of sufficient reason and you
were a physicist
um the real question you're going to be
interested in is something like well
what are the reasons uh that were
sufficient to bring this thing about and
so the reason your joke is funny
um is because it's contentless like yes
yes yes I know the initial conditions
and the laws whatever bring things about
but my question was more detailed than
that I wanted to know a more detailed
story or maybe a more local story
that
but from the kind of philosophical
standpoint
um I really do think that just thinking
about the initial conditions and the
laws is enough to start generating some
of the puzzles that animated people and
thinking about the principle of
sufficient reason so for instance you
might be very worried about free will
you might think to yourself oh my gosh I
just stole this candy bar
um everything happens for a reason let
me now reason my way back to the initial
conditions of the laws why did I steal
this candy bar well because the initial
conditions were thus and so and the laws
were yay and blay and those things
guarantee that was sufficient for me to
steal this candy bar and so why is
everyone so mad at me it wasn't my idea
to set the initial conditions and the
laws as they are
um in what sense do I have you know
freedom and that that little argument I
mean I'm not saying that wasn't the most
careful version of the problem of free
will or something but what's interesting
about that little argument is it doesn't
presuppose anything but the actual
content event of the laws or the content
of the initial conditions the mere fact
that the world is somehow guaranteed to
be such that everything that happens
happens for a reason generates this
puzzle or this anxiety about free will
but I guess this is why it seems
challenging to me to be a metaphysician
because I I don't think that there
actually is the principle of sufficient
reason I don't think that that's true uh
but it's seductive right and you know
it's seductive to say something like
well without laws things wouldn't make
sense but yeah what do we know really
like how confident are we when we say
things like that or how confident are we
that when we're reasoning about things
that are very different than our
universe that we can say things that are
not overly tainted by our Real World
Experience here's how here's how I like
when I'm trying to like sleep at night
and tell myself that I'm doing a real
thing here is the story that I that I
give myself
uh for any kind of inquiry you have to
start by taking some things for granted
and if you don't take some things for
granted you just can't get anything done
um and for me the kinds of projects that
I'm into like stuff about laws causes
that kind of thing what what you're
meant to take for granted is the thought
that okay there's this
there's this intellectual human
Enterprise
um that's been successful sort of cross
historically let's call this thing
scientific inquiry
and as the philosopher let's try to step
back and see if we can find
commonalities between different episodes
of successful science
and one thing that arguably that this is
all debatable of course but one thing
that arguably is a commonality between
many different successful scientific
theories is that they make a distinction
between the claims and the theory that
are meant to be true or maybe
universally true and the claims that are
meant to be laws there's some kind of
project that involves distinguishing
some of these things some of these true
sentences as laws and some of these true
sentences is merely true sentences
um same thing for causes and correlation
so across many different successful
episodes of science there's some like
pressure to make this distinction
between mere correlations and something
above and beyond correlations causes
or for the stuff I'm particularly
interested in uh enormously common that
episodes of scientific inquiry develop
theories that have probabilistic content
um but uh you know with the standard
interpretation of quantum mechanics we
get this sense that not all
probabilistic content is created equal
some of it is really getting at
something important about the world
where some of it is just a reflection of
our ignorance so you start by sort of
taking for granted that there's this
successful Enterprise it's made these
distinctions
and then the job of a philosopher isn't
to say oh now I know for sure there are
laws of nature I have no idea if there
are laws of nature that sounds bananas
and if I had to bet I would just bet you
know whatever I don't know that we're a
simulation or something I don't know
what the world is really like
but the thought is okay well this this
successful epistemic inquiry is making
this distinction between these two kinds
of things laws and non-laws let me now
go in and try to figure out what the
purpose of that distinction is
and if I can say anything at all about
what the world would have to be like to
ground that distinction as being
genuinely about the world like if we're
saying some things are laws what are we
really saying about the world and so to
do that project I don't need to have
much confidence that like I'm really
getting on to what the world is really
like or we as people are really getting
on to what the world is like I'm making
a bunch of conditional claims all of
which I might give up on immediately so
the first is that there's something that
deserves the name scientific inquiry the
second is that it's been successful in
these various ways the third is that it
makes this distinction you know I'm
making lots of assumptions and then I'm
just trying to figure out okay what how
could I build a theory of what reality
is like
on which it would make sense to
distinguish between laws and non-laws or
in which it would make sense to
distinguish between causes and
non-causes and in which human beings
could discover those things and they
would be important for inquiry so it's
something like that and I think for that
I don't have to be very confident that
I'm getting things right or something
it's like a just so story or it's like a
proof of concept or something how could
how could these ideas all fit together
and make sense well you mentioned causes
several times I have uh I would like to
get into what this means because I'm
fascinated by this I I have an angle
here you can tell me whether I'm on any
track that is right or wrong uh you know
Bertrand Russell famously said that once
we understand physics there's no more
causes is that like a friend of yours or
yeah he was a he was a name dropping
that's amazing sir yes uh the idea being
that you know once you have classical
mechanics in hand uh
it's just a matter of patterns right
it's just one thing after another and in
fact as LaPlace pointed out you could
run forward or backward equally well so
it's not that anything goes there's
still laws but they're not written as a
series of causes and then effects and so
my angle is that that's true at the
level of fundamental physics but then in
the macroscopic world where we only have
some probabilities and things like that
we have an arrow of time and it becomes
possible to talk about causes preceding
effects and you have to dig into like
alternative worlds possible worlds and
counter factuals and things like that
and that's fun and a good thing to do
that's it that's my angle I'm trying to
actually do it but I haven't done it yet
so tell us what what the modern
metaphysician thinks about these things
I think I think if those are the two
basic angles for the modern meta
position so
um I mean the way I would try to
introduce the topic is again to say
something like look uh start with this
very metaphysically innocent notion that
they're just these patterns uh in which
things happen
um we might call those correlations so
there are relationships of sometimes
constant conjunctions sometimes
statistical correlation this thing
happens and this other thing happens
um and there's this thought
um maybe it's not a thought that we get
from physics so I take the I take the
moral that maybe we don't sort of get
this thought until we go up more
macroscopic or something but there's
this thought that not all of these
correlations are created equal and one
question that I'm interested in is
what it is that we're looking for when
we look for something more than a
correlation
um why what in our goals of theorizing
are pushing us to posit something over
and above this correlation but whatever
the causal relations are there's
something over and above these
correlation relations when I say this
thing over and above does that suggest
anything to you it's like a philosophy
thing but maybe I mean I worry about it
because it suggests spooky Essences of
some sort which I'm against in principle
it definitely suggests something spooky
yeah so
um so now the metaphysician starts to
debate about like what that spooky thing
is and the thinnest sort of answer is
that all that spooky thing is is that
you know a partic you might have
particular instances of like one-off
correlations or small correlations but
the causes are like the big Global
correlations the the patterns that are
that are that hold at a totally
Universal scale so something like the
thought that what the laws of nature are
are sort of the patterns that are
they're held most globally in the entire
picture whatever the thing is so that
could be like a very go ahead yeah can I
try to try to wrap my brain around this
because I think this is an interesting
distinction that I haven't quite heard
before so if I throw a baseball and it
goes a certain number of feet that's a
little local microscopic event but the
cause in or at least run one aspect of
the cause in this telling is the fact
that many many baseballs get thrown and
many other things get thrown and we
abstract those in the laws of physics
and that that's as that Global law that
is the cause not the specific me
throwing it's not the global law that's
the cause but what makes it the case
that that particular event was an
instance of the causal relation say is
that it's an instance of this big Global
pattern say the classical laws or
something okay and is does the notion of
causes and effects involve
counterfactuals necessarily like I I
think yeah good it does so we were
saying we got into this by sort of
saying what are the what are the
Contemporary options and contemporary
option number one is to try to
understand causation just in terms of
those global patterns so somehow go from
um claims about the global patterns to
claims about this thing cause this thing
and The Meta position is going to weave
those all together to try to reduce that
this thing caused this thing to this
stuff about the global patterns and
nothing about factuals
now
another the other sort of popular way to
go and I think it's fair to say or at
least it would have been definitely fair
to say 15 years ago like the the way to
go or the sort of most
currently popular way to go is to tell
some kind of story that relates uh
causes not to these big regularities but
to these claims about counterfactuals
these claims about what would have
happened under various conditions
um one one reason that you might want to
pause before you move to team counter
factual is that one thing team
regularity really has going for them is
that the stuff they believe in is very
normal
so they believe in like the distribution
of events yeah and they believe in like
patterns in the distribution of events
and that's not spooky right that's like
normal boys the real world the actual
world yeah the actual world the counter
factuals it's less clear
um what's making them true and it's less
clear sort of what they're saying about
the world because they don't on the face
of it they don't say anything about what
the world is like they say things about
what the world would be like if things
were different and both how we come to
know those things and what about the
world could make them true is much more
fraught than the question how could we
know the regularities or what could make
the regularities true very easy to say
what would make them true harder but
still we could imagine saying something
about how we know that they're true but
now that you've got these sort of weird
claims about what the world would have
been like
um and a very natural thought at least I
think it's a very natural thought is
that what you would have naively said is
oh it's because look the reason why I
know that
um had I not thrown the window sorry the
window had I not thrown the rock the
window wouldn't have broken it's really
know that throwing rocks is a cause of
Windows breaking and like normal
atmospheric conditions are to cause
so you might have put causes on the
bottom of counterfactuals you might have
thought oh it's the causal facts in our
world that make the counter factuals
true and the picture that you were
suggesting which is a popular picture is
to try to reverse that to say no there
are some counterfactual facts that are
grounding or making true the causal
claims of the world and so now you want
to sort of know what makes the counter
factuals true and what are they about
and now you're off you're ready so I
think you've made a good first step but
I want to hear more about what's making
your counterfactuals true and how you
think we come to know them sure by I am
on team counterfactual and the reason
why is because I worry the team
regularity will end up living in the
physicist joke that the only cause for
anything is the laws of physics and the
initial conditions of the universe
whereas I can counter factually say if
things had been different if I hadn't
thrown the rock the window wouldn't have
broken and I know that people are easily
going to say yeah but what if someone
else throws a rocks and break the window
then the window would have broken anyway
even if you hadn't thrown your rock and
that's why it's hard and I get that it's
hard full employment for metaphysicians
but yeah but I also very much get the
the worry that you're sort of uh peaking
at that in order to think about counter
factuals I have to go well beyond the
actual world and to all these other
possible worlds and is how legit is that
I mean so how legit is that I mean
that's definitely uh thinking about that
project is highly legit
um and then thinking that there's going
to be a successful answer to that
question is certainly legit from many
people's perspective and then you know
if I'm team regularity I'm like good
luck bro like yeah let me let me see you
do that it's it's my skepticism that's
ever going to be a successful project
that makes me you know stay and twirl
away at Team regularity
um so the the question of sort of how to
understand the philosophers have a term
of art uh Moodle Moodle facts for facts
about what could be true or what must be
true or what would be true under various
conditions and and it's a very hard
question to see either how to reduce
those claims about the modal facts to
what actually happens so go from what
could happen to what actually happens or
what would happen to what actually
happens ground them all in the actual
World it seems very hard or posit
something
um
over and above or in addition to the
actual world that can serve as the
grounders or truthmakers of those things
so just I mean just famously just to
give you a taste of how how this can go
uh there's a very influential
philosopher named David Lewis
um David Lewis was a fan of using the
kind of possible World talk that you
were invoking a second ago to think
about modality many people are fans of
using the possible World talk to think
about modality but Lewis thought those
possible worlds were actual concrete
worlds so that when we were making a
claim about what would happen under
various conditions uh that claim was
made True by
by actual concrete worlds in which there
were you know anything you could imagine
were actual concrete worlds so that
would be like a really metaphysically
robust you believe in lots of things
apart from the actual world to make
those kind of factuals true
so yeah tough tough questions it seems a
little team counterfactual is popular so
it does seem a little extravagant but
that's okay extravagance is something I
I've yeah there's other options I don't
want to suggest that that's the only
option well but so let me let me home in
on since I have you here I'm gonna take
advantage of this let me hop in on what
I what I gather to be one of the issues
that that Lewis would say something like
yeah you know something is a cause of
something else if in another possible
world if a hadn't happened then B would
not have happened but then he has to add
it's like the nearest possible World
we're gonna change a but we're not going
to change anything else about the world
and then the big question there is what
is nearest supposed to mean like it I
could imagine a possible world where I
throw the Rock at the window and then
just as The Rock is going to hit the
window I violate the laws of physics so
the rock just goes through the window
and that's a very close possible world
but I violated the laws of physics so
that seems like a real really big
difference and so I guess how do you
measure what's a big change in the world
versus what's a small change seems to be
a looming issue here yeah so
maybe one way to try to help to clarify
what's going on here so many people like
this possible World talk as a way to
um make sense of what we mean or what
the truth conditions are or what the
semantics are of various counterfactual
claims so so forget about our problem
about causes for just a second just
think about
um ordinary counterfactuals consider the
counterfactual
um if Katie were a kid in 2023 Katie
would have Tick-Tock right uh is that
counter factual true or false well
there's a way of thinking about it that
makes it seem true and there's a way of
thinking about it that makes it seem
false way of thinking about it makes it
seem true Katie would have Tick Tock is
that like when I was a kid in the 80s I
was very influenced by Trends I just
wanted to fit in and so if we sort of
hold fixed that fact about me that Katie
is somebody who when she was a kid was
focused on Trends it seems like well if
I were a kid now I would still be
interested in Trends and like Tick Tock
is the is the trend on the other hand
another feature of me is that now at the
age of 41 or whatever I don't know
anything about the technology the kids
are using If We Hold fixed that fit if
we hold fix that fact about me then we
want to say well if Katie were a kid
today she wouldn't have Tick Tock
because she like doesn't know anything
she's like a Luddite or whatever she
doesn't know anything about tech so it's
a general fact of counterfactuals that
when we're evaluating them we can make
them seem true 2 by fixing the
background context in one way or we can
make those seem false by fixing the
background context in another way and
that closeness or that similarity
relation is is how a philosopher is
thinking about what's going on in those
different evaluations we want to give in
the counter factual one context told you
that the sort of relevant worlds to look
at are worlds where Katie's a kid and
she's into Trends another context told
you that the relevant worlds to look at
were worlds where Katie's a kid and
she's like a lot of it
and so now when it comes to the question
of like how to understand these counter
factuals that are grounding causation
there's this sort of question about like
okay well we need some we need some
similarity relation just like we do with
every counter fractal we're evaluating
but now it needs to be kind of like the
real one or the physically important one
um and trying to figure out what the
sort of like
physically important uh relation of
closeness on possible worlds is
something that like Lewis and other
metaphysicians who are interested in
kind of some people are just using
possible worlds as a model to make
counterfactuals come out right and some
people are using possible worlds to tell
them about what the nature of reality is
like and if you're doing it for that
second project you better have something
to say about what the proprietary
closeness relationship is that I feel
like this wasn't a successful speech
anyway because this thing is a problem
and
what you said Is You
um as you noticed that the sort of
closest worlds that you're going to need
to get your kind of factuals to operate
in the right way are going to be worlds
with slightly different laws of nature
what he called Small Miracles or
whatever well I think I think it was a
very successful speech because it it
brings up what I think is something to
help you fall asleep at night when
you're worrying about whether any of
this is is useful I mean there's a glib
answer to the wood kdb on Tick Tock
question which is I don't know there's
there's no such thing as Katie who is a
kid now because Katie wasn't a kid now
so don't ask me that question but the
response to that is but what we care
about are questions like did this
patient get better because we gave them
this medicine and that's an equally
counterfactual question so even though
we're playing games with the metaphysics
to make it dramatic the underlying
issues are kind of pretty down to earth
yeah that's right so um uh I really I
really like that speech and I really
sort of want to emphasize it
um
it seems like metaphysicians are just
like
jerks we're just like jerks who are out
there saying nonsense for like no reason
or something
um but it really is true that what's
driving us isn't uh well depending on
the person but like I'm not trying to be
an obscurious Jerk It's just that when
you start saying very normal things like
this explains this as you said did the
medicine explain the recovery or was the
medicine that Placebo just a very
natural question like that immediately
as you point out starts to invoke
counterfactual comparisons you want to
say well would the patient have gotten
better without the medicine that's
immediately a counterfactual and that's
not just some goofy counterfactual but
whether Katie would have liked Tick Tock
that's the kind of factual that's going
to ground actual research that we really
care about now I'm not saying that like
we have to understand what that question
means in order to do the actual research
but but it but it's a it's a desire to
understand better simple claims like
that that drives the metaphysician into
positive things that will look pretty
weird from the perspective of just on
the street Comet sets so that that's
exactly the kind of question we're
trying to do and this all these
questions are hard enough if in the
possible world where Isaac Newton had
been right and the laws of physics were
deterministic and you know laplace's
demon could be telling us what's going
to happen next
but he wasn't right we have quantum
mechanics so we have certain events that
let's be
super precise about it there are certain
events for which our best physical
theories can at most predict the
probability with which they will happen
does that throw a monkey wrench into our
attempts to find cause effect relations
in the world yeah great uh well I will
tell you how I think about the answer to
this question but I don't want to say
that it's like the way people think
about the answer to this by the way this
is just a very philosopher way to talk
like philosophers always want to give
every possible answer to the question
and then say who knows right but I I
think here on the podcast you're welcome
to tell us what you think is correct I
just want you to know the menu of
options because I want to mitigate the
hate mail that I'm going to get after
this okay so
um many many different things uh you
could think
um about the switch from
us uh
uh the success of deterministic pictures
to the apparent predictive success of
indeterministic pictures here's how I
think about it
um I think there used to be a pretty
strong methodological principle guiding
scientific inquiry across many different
instances of scientific inquiry there
was something like this
um to the extent that you have
probabilistic content in your theory
um that probabilistic content is a
marker of the non-ideality of your
theory that a kind of Ideal theory of
the world maybe this Theory isn't
achievable maybe we could never know it
maybe we could never find it but the
kind of Ideal theory of the world will
be fully deterministic and to the extent
that your theory has some probabilities
in it that's a marker of your ignorance
maybe not in a way that we blame you for
or something but there's but there's
something that you haven't filled in yet
and you're still trying to make pretty
accurate predictions using your
probabilistic model
um but but that's a marker of
incompleteness so statistical mechanics
would have been like that
yeah exactly so you've got these exactly
um and and you see this pressure to uh
exactly the system mechanical project is
trying to recover the determinism at the
bottom from these probabilities at the
top exactly
um for me and for people who do projects
like mine uh the a big shift in the at
least temporary temporary popularity of
the standard interpretation of quantum
mechanics where these probabilities are
not taken to be a mere expression of our
ignorance but as describing something
irreducibly stochastic about the
structure of the world
um that shift was a really big deal
because it represented a giving up on or
maybe this maybe it shows that this Norm
for determinism was never there or maybe
it shows that there was a switch we we
let go of the norm and said okay we'll
now accept that you can have a complete
theory in some sense or an ideal theory
in some sense that's irreducibly
probabilistic that's from like a big
picture Viewpoint was a big shift in the
way science is conducted yeah and it it
corresponds to a big shift in how we
have to under understand certain
projects that science was undergoing so
what is prediction
I understand a prediction now it looks
like has to change and our understanding
of explanation looks like it has to
change so maybe our old understanding of
prediction was something like ideal
prediction is just saying what happens
like before it happens or before you
check but now
um we don't want to be in a position
where we can say what happens before it
happens
um if anything that's going to be a
marker of us having failed because we're
thinking the world is really genuinely
indeterministic so now our predictive
Enterprises aren't to get what happens
right it's to I don't know match our
credences to the chances or match our
Credence as to the probabilities given
by the theory we want to make
predictions at the rate at which you
know we're doing something predictably
different now
and as we were talking about at the
start with the principle of sufficient
reason we're arguably doing something
different in our explanatory project or
we need to rethink our exploratory
project because now we're not trying to
find sufficient reasons for things to
happen there are no sufficient reasons
for things to happen instead we're
trying to do something else you offered
maybe we're trying to find sufficient
reasons for the probabilities to obtain
um other options too so uh for me the
big shift between
um more classical mechanics to the
quantum picture isn't so much about
trying to figure out like
what is the right way to interpret the
probabilities of quantum mechanics those
are people's projects that's just not my
project what do those probabilities say
about the world to what extent are they
real to what extent do they show that
there's something strange going on with
observation and reality there's all
those kind of like local questions but
there's a kind of big Global question
which is like oh wait are our science
changed one of its major guiding norms
and what does that tell us about the
nature of explanation and prediction and
so like our story about causation has to
be really different
um in a fundamentally indeterministic
World
um and thinking about that is one of the
things I like to think about but maybe
you would agree with me I get my heckles
are raised when people say
because of quantum mechanics there's no
such thing as cause and effect
because yeah
that's too far who said that dude there
are people on the internet who say
things like that okay all right yeah no
I don't I don't think that's true but
you could you could imagine I mean look
you could imagine taking the view that
you that look causation
uh explanation prediction those were
things that we thought we could do in a
deterministic world now that we found
out that the world was indeterministic
we have to give up on all those things I
think that's obviously the wrong
reaction I think the right reaction is
oh now we have to reconceptualize all
this thing
so that they make sense well especially
because we never were laplace's demon we
never had all that information so it was
always at best some probabilities
getting involved there yeah that's
that's exactly right there's a question
that gets related to this which is the
presentism versus eternalism question on
a recent ask me anything episode someone
said if you were living in a truly
indeterministic Universe can you still
be an eternalist because you don't know
exactly what's going to happen in the
future and my answer was sure why not
it's just that there is a future but we
don't know which one it is that that's
our ability to predict that's not the
fundamental ontology of it and then the
the comment on YouTube which I happen to
stumble across was well then what
difference does it make you know if if
you can be an eternalist no matter
what's happening then it seems pretty
content free to be an eternalist versus
a presentist and I might I want to say
yeah that's fine I don't really I'm not
I'm not you know in love with being an
eternalist I just am but if you don't
want to be and it still gets you all the
predictions that I'm that I'm kind of
happy with that I don't know if I'm
giving up too easily there well so I I
definitely agree with you that
eternalism and indeterminism are totally
compatible uh uh there's like I think
thinking about that is pretty
interesting because
um normally when we think about in
determinism we tend to think about it in
a heavily epistemic way we think about
it we want to sort of describe it as uh
oh yeah we can have a complete story
about the world at a time uh we could
have a complete story about the laws of
nature so we wouldn't know what was
going to happen in the future if
eternalism is true you could know what
was going to happen in the future
without that in any way impeding the
indeterminism of the world that there's
a fact of the matter about what happens
in the future is totally consistent with
there being some probability of what was
going to happen in the future
um but your your enemy on YouTube who's
accused you of the contentlessness of uh
uh eternalism I I don't think it's I
think they were thinking that the the
good thing about eternalism or something
was there's going to make sense of the
deterministic and deterministic
distinction and I don't think that's
right so I think
um whatever the appeal is of eternalism
or presentism uh it's not driven by a
by wanting a picture that makes sense of
say deterministic or indeterministic
relationships I think it's much more
driven by uh
well it's driven by lots of things but
but it's driven by even just naive
things about thinking whether or not
there's a fact of the matter about what
will happen in the future so uh today
you're gonna eat a sandwich for lunch
let's just stipulate that um you haven't
eaten the sandwich yet if I say Sean has
a sandwich for lunch uh is that true and
is it true now and if it's true now what
makes it true and if presentism were
were true what could make true these
claims about the future or the past if
there is no future and past that's a
much more humble way for your YouTube
enemy to get motivated about the
distinction between terrorist
presentation but I'm hardcore on your
side eternalism totally consistent with
indeterminism but then this leads right
into what I really wanted one of the
things I really wanted to talk about
with you which is newcomb's paradox oh
yeah and I have very strong feelings
about newcomb's Paradox I'm not gonna
you seem like a guy who would I would
and I'm not gonna tell you what they are
I want you to give us your take first
well all all good people are two boxers
do people know this puzzle no one boxing
is absolutely correct one boxing is
absolutely correct yeah but the people
don't know the puzzle so explain the
puzzle
great here's what newcomb's Paradox is
you're gonna play a game uh in the game
you can either pick an opaque Box by
itself
or you can pick an opaque box and a
clear box right and the bean says I'm
terrible remembering the rules of all
these paradoxes of like Sleeping Beauty
who was it Tuesday or what you know so I
I get that uh it's it's hard to get it
right right on the spot so we're picking
either okay the opaque box or both boxes
right but the opaque box or both boxes
and what's in the boxes and the the uh
opaque box
um either has zero dollars or a million
dollars in it
and the clear box you could just see in
the Box it's got a hundred bucks in it
are we doing this right so far I think
that sounds right I think and the bean
the bean tells you look uh rub I'm gonna
make a prediction
if I predict that you're gonna take both
boxes I'm gonna put zero dollars in the
opaque box
and if I predict that you're gonna take
just the opaque Box by itself I'm gonna
put a million dollars in there
uh so the bean is going to make a
prediction before you pick
the bean doesn't control you
and the bean will have either put the
money in or not put the money in before
your pick so when it's time for you to
pick there's an opaque box it either has
zero dollars or a million dollars in it
and there's a clear box with a hundred
dollars in it
and you can pick either both boxes or
just the opaque box yeah now you have
some background information which is
that people have been playing this game
show for time and Memorial
every time somebody has picked both
boxes
the bean has correctly predicted that
they were going to pick both boxes and
so they put zero dollars in the opaque
box so there's an extremely high
correlation between picking both boxes
and walking out of the game with just a
hundred dollars
on the other hand when people decide to
pick just the opaque box the bean has an
extremely high track record of having
predicted that correctly and therefore
putting a million dollars in the opaque
box so there's a enormously instanced
regularity an end of as big as you like
that people who pick one box walk away
with a million dollars and people who
pick both boxes walk away with only a
hundred dollars and now the bean has
made their prediction they've put the
money in the Box it's time for you to
pick and you Sean well I Katie yeah I
pick both boxes and you're gonna walk
away with just a hundred dollars I'm
gonna pick one box and walk away with a
million great well that's why you are an
enormously successful
[Laughter]
what is your justification who do you
want to go first you want to give your
explanation why
yeah sure I'll go first I had in front
of me two boxes
I didn't know how much was in the opaque
box
I knew there was a hundred dollars in
the clear box my choice
can't make any causal impact on what's
going to be in the opaque box I know
that no matter what I do I'll do better
by picking both boxes
uh because that always gets a hundred
dollar bonus from that clear box I pick
up so there I am I take both boxes I
excitedly opened the opaque box and oh
there's nothing in it and I go home a
loser but at least I have my rationality
at least I can tell my grandkids that I
understood what I was doing right
whereas I will have a million dollars I
think my grandkids are gonna be happier
with me sweet because the way that I
think about it is uh I there are two
possible worlds that I could be in
there's a possible world where there's a
million dollars in the opaque box in a
possible world where there's not and it
is true that
the fact that I'm in one possible world
or another
pre-exists me making the decision
so there's nothing changes on the basis
of me making the decision like you said
but the the rub is that this magical
being who is the game show host does
know which possible world I'm in and is
telling me
and so I'm gonna believe the magical
being who knows more about this at a
possible worlds and I'm gonna
pick living in the world where I get a
million dollars that makes perfect sense
to me it's perfectly rational
yeah great let me ask you this so I I
understand everything you said totally
see it appeal there you are standing in
front of the two boxes you're fully
intending to take the one box
um what do you think would have happened
at that moment what you're about to pick
boxes what do you think would have
happened if you would have taken both
boxes the one box would have been empty
the opaque box would have been empty how
how would that have worked
well it either
it's not there right exactly and I don't
know and the I mean the trick of the
question would as in many metaphysics
thought experiments you can always just
say but there are no magical beings like
this okay but the the trick is that
magical being this comes from me being a
determinist and not a determinist sorry
I shouldn't say that an eternalist right
as as thinking that there is a fact
about the future even if I don't know
what it is and you're telling me there's
another person who does know what it is
and they're telling me and the fact is
that there's only two possible Futures
one in which I pick both boxes and get a
hundred one of which I picked one box
and get a million I'm gonna do the one
where I get a million because I like
money
I I totally get the choice I'm a little
skeptical that the eternalism plays much
of a much of a role in this reasoning
um but but I it is true that the one
boxer gets to brag about um being rich
um I have a bit of a I have a shtick
about this okay uh which I haven't
published yet but my about this is
the problem with this because I
don't know any facts about any of the
material well but there's just there's
this religion called Calvinism right yes
and uh I don't know if this is actually
true of real Calvinism but my my sort of
you know elementary school version of
Calvinism is that uh Calvinists had this
picture about predestination
um God picks whether or not you're going
to heaven or hell before you sort of
live your life God writes down in God's
book of Heaven or Hell
whether or not you're going to heaven or
hell
and then you might think well if God's
already picked what's my motivation for
living a good life
um
and the answer the answer the Calvinists
give again supposedly is um well as you
like obviously God wouldn't have picked
a bad person to go to heaven God looks
at your whole life and sees what you do
and on the basis of that decides if
you're going to go to heaven or hell so
when you do good acts what you're doing
is you're giving yourself evidence
you're not making it the case that you
go to heaven you're giving yourself
evidence that God pre-ordained you to go
to heaven and when you do bad acts
you're giving yourself evidence that God
pre-ordained you to going to hell and I
think the structure of this is exactly
like the newcomb's problem so the
calvinist sort of gives you a one box
answer which is that even though it's
already written in the book whether or
not you're going to go to heaven or hell
still don't sin not because your sinning
has any causal effect on whether or not
you're going to go to heaven or hell but
because it's evidence that
uh you know you're sitting as evidence
that you're going to go to hell and you
don't want to create a situation where
you have a bunch of evidence that you're
going to hell because then you'll
probably go to hell I love that I think
you've made Calvinism make intellectual
sense to me I might become a calvinist
now
I will I'll be friendlier to the
calvinist so I meet on the street which
is not very many of them but
okay okay good and then we're gonna add
another wrinkle to this whole game of uh
predestination and whatever by saying
well what if I have a time machine
there's a long-standing set of questions
about if I had a time machine I could go
to the Past could I and separately
should I do things to change how things
turn out and presumably this is right up
the metaphysical alley of people who
think about these questions absolutely
no makes no difference it's fun to think
about
perfect No One's Gonna limit yeah right
so uh is there I mean I can imagine
different versions of time travel one in
which you do change things one of which
you don't one of which there's different
timelines come into existence you know
is is there like a retinue or a menu of
possibilities that we think about
metaphysically
yeah
um so uh again name dropping this dude
David Lewis
um so there's a I guess there's a
tradition among science fiction authors
that Lewis sort of piggybacks off of of
trying to think about a a particular
kind of time travel scenario so some
time travel scenarios and they're
getting like popular and TBE and media
or stuff or these kind of like
Multiverse time travel scenarios where
when I go back to the past say to right
some wrong what I actually do is I
travel to a different timeline or
something and when I'm in that timeline
I uh prevent you know whatever I want to
stop the bully who picks on me and in
the I go to a different timeline where I
you know tie the bully shoes together or
something
um
what whatever interesting questions
there are about that kind of model uh
that kind of model isn't the one that
philosophers have spent the most time
thinking about and it's not the kind
that science fiction authors at least a
while ago didn't spend that much time
thinking about and the reason is because
the sort of fantasy is to like go back
and change the past and the thought is
well in the Multiverse story you don't
go back and change the past you go
somewhere else and do something else
like I want I want to get the boy who
you know harassed me in my childhood
going to some other universe or whatever
some other bully that's not my fantasy
so we think about the sort of single
timeline time travel stories let me just
let me just I have someone to quickly
mention the fact you're completely
correct in your impression that in the
movies and TV this multiple timeline
thing is the is the latest rage but I
have noticed that even though it is not
intellectually respectable the writers
still like their timeline the best so
there's all these stories of like our
heroes completely erasing entire
timelines from existence which makes
them you know genocidal Maniac monsters
I know it's terrible and so I want to
stand up for all the people whose
timelines get a raise for narrative just
because it's not your timeline doesn't
mean right just click it away or snap it
away or whatever it's brutal that's my
thought but anyway you so we like the
single single time stories
but the bummer about those is that it
seems as though you can't change the
past yeah
um
and you know that sort of ruins the
fantasy but the kind of classic
philosopher's Paradox is this thing
called The Grandfather's Paradox and
basically the story is just you hate
your grandpa as people do or whatever no
people love their grandmas but you hate
your grandpa
you want to go back in time and murder
your grandpa you don't want him to live
to the age of 30 or whatever you're
really angry at your grandpa
uh and it seems like you should be able
to do that it's you know if you're dead
set on harming someone I I don't know
what philosophers always do like the
most violent upsetting version of
whatever the case is so sorry about
slipping all the violence in but anyway
he should be able to kill your
grandfather shouldn't be that hard it's
not like your grandfather's a superhero
or something you're gonna travel back in
time
uh but on the other hand of course if
you kill your grandfather
um before your father is born then your
father won't have you and so you can
just sort of as you're trying to kill
your grandfather you can just look down
at your own body and see oh I'm gonna
fail to kill my grandfather
um and I know that because I know that
you know things happen in the future uh
that are inconsistent with my killing my
grandfather so it seems like there's a
sense in which you can kill your
grandfather and a sense in which you
can't kill your grandfather and that
sounds incoherent
so what's the what's the solution well
and it seems to me very similar to
nukem's Paradox in the sense that what
is new is that rather than a magical
being it's you who has some information
about the future right so your personal
future is the universe sorry I guess
your personal past is the universe's
future once you've traveled into the
past right like you know that your
grandfather will have kids and you like
you say you look down your body and you
have evidence of it yeah and so like one
way of uh one way that I like of like
making this feel extremely weird is you
know imagine you try to kill your
grandfather a bunch of times you're
gonna fail every single time it's it's
gonna start looking like this hilarious
comedy of heirs I mean the first time
you try to kill your grandfather you're
gonna like I don't know a bird is Gonna
Fly by as you're trying you're gonna
fail the second time you're gonna slip
on a banana peel the third you know who
knows you know you're gonna fail for
sure is that you're gonna fail every
time even though this task is apparently
easy you are well prepared for it
um
somehow you're gonna fail and it's not
like some Cosmic it's like the time
police is going to come and arrest you
it's just that a series of events is
going to transpire such that no matter
how many times you attempt to kill your
grandfather from you from your first
personal perspective it's gonna seem
like there's some kind of Magical Force
protecting your grandfather because no
matter what you do
you're unable to to get it do we learn
any lessons philosophically from because
I completely agree with your conclusion
there uh what philosophical lessons do
we learn is something I'm very touchy
about because people I've published
about time travel and people goof on me
all the time because I think it's a
non-serious topic and I see their
perspective but here's a reason that I
like to think well so one reason I like
to think about time travel is a reason
you've already alluded to which is that
it when we're thinking about this kind
of eternalist picture
um it we want to be able to cleanly
separate claims about what we know or
could in principle know about the future
from what is the case about the future
or whether the future is determined and
it could be hard to sort of cleanly
separate those conceptually this time
travel story helps you sort of cleanly
separate claims from what you know about
the future to sort of what the causal
impact is that you have on the future
but so let me ask you a question about
um what you think about this time travel
case
so take some kind of local system that
you think is genuinely indeterministic
it could be like something radioactive
decaying or just to have it simple let's
just say we have a genuinely
indeterministic coin we're doing a coin
toss and somehow it's really
indeterministic even though you know
that's not physically real or whatever
just you know pretend
so you watch the coin get flipped and it
lands on heads
and now you travel back in time to the
beginning of the coin flip
on the one hand we've said the coin flip
is genuinely indeterministic
and we haven't changed anything physical
about the coin so you going back in time
doesn't change anything intrinsic to the
setup of our experiment
you know that the coin is going to land
heads
um the question is
is it consistent with what you know
about the future that the coin still has
a 50 50 chance of Landing heads or is
the right thing to think now that oh
there's something about your time travel
that has transformed this otherwise
indeterministic system into a
deterministic system good I my answer
would be that we have converted it to a
deterministic system in the sense that I
am a eternalist who's going to be open
to the closest we can come to genuinely
publicistic indeterministic events which
is just that something is going to
happen but we don't know what it is it's
purely epistemological and so what
you're saying is that because I have a
time machine now I do know what's going
to happen so now it's deterministic now
I think we know it's going to happen
great and does that imply something so
it seems like that implies something
that might have been surprising but
maybe you won't be surprised by this
which is that the uh whether or not the
sort of experimental setup was
indeterministic or deterministic turns
out to now be a global feature of the
entire system rather than an intrinsic
or local feature to the mechanics that
were underwriting the coin flip yeah I
think that's perfectly Fair because what
I really have
worries about issues with is the notion
of true indeterminism like as opposed to
fake indeterminism or whatever and the
the example I always have in mind is you
know someone is reading out a list of
numbers in base 10 that you know digits
between zero and nine and you strive and
strive to understand what is going on
how to predict what number is going to
come next and you do all the statistical
tests you find no correlations it looks
as random as it is possible for random
to be and then they reveal at the end
that they're literally just giving you
the digits of pi starting with the
millionth digit right so secretly there
was a deterministic rule that was
telling you what's going on you just
didn't know it I don't I don't know what
is true in determinism and what is not
there's I I get that epistemologically I
might know what's going to happen or not
but something's going to happen
something is definitely going to happen
are you saying that like
I don't know what you're saying yet okay
are you saying that
it sounded like you were saying
um because take any particular
distribution of events uh it's
consistent with that distribution of
events both that it was the object of a
secretly deterministic process or it was
the product of a genuinely stochastic
process the the frequency with which the
event occurs sort of under determines
whether or not it was produced by a
deterministic system or an
indeterministic system and so are you
thinking
because because the outcomes are always
going to be consistent with both options
we should default to thinking there's a
secret deterministic explanation or
something oh no I would I wouldn't say
that I do think that in the list of all
lists of numbers most of them do not
have any nice algorithmic simplification
like like digits of pi so in the in the
list of all things that could happen in
the future if it's not deterministic
most of them will not have any secret
underlying deterministic process I'm
just saying I'm not sure there is a
difference between saying I I know of
the simple deterministic rule underlying
it versus I know of the future list of
things that will actually happen right I
mean in in both cases it's a matter of
my knowledge and the the
existence of a simple deterministic rule
underlying it is interesting but maybe
I'll get it maybe I won't and that's
okay there you know there's I'm not
being very clear this is my fault here
uh I I get that there is a question
what are the simplest most compact form
of the laws of physics to tell us what
happened in the future but I'm open to
those simply being a list of things that
happen in the future it still counts as
a law
I see so um
and this is okay good so this is getting
us back to newcomb's puzzle so when I
when I say about nucleus puzzle Sean
what are you doing you're you're picking
the one box that's bananas you should
pick both boxes
um what I'm thinking is that you know
there's this genuine fact of the matter
at a particular time
um about what the causal influence will
be between picking the boxes and the
predictor and the causal there is no
causal influence so go for it and your
thought is look um
there's no substantive difference
between whether or not my influence over
the thing is causal or evidential all I
really care is about the evidential
relations and so whether or not this
thing is like backed by some underlying
reality isn't important to me it's it's
all about the epistemology so if I know
about the outcome of the system ahead of
time it's got to be a deterministic
system because all there is to the
notion of determinism is something about
what you can know and when you can know
it or something I think that that's
roughly true although you know I haven't
stated it perfectly but it does seem
consistent to me with the idea that you
can go into the past as a time traveler
in a single World universe and the
things that you know have to happen in
your future now are are going to happen
you can't prevent them but there's other
things you don't know where you would
act exactly as if you have free will
about doing this or that
um do you think
do you think there's a difference
so suppose God were building a world
God's Building two different worlds the
first world that God is building you can
know the initial conditions and the laws
and use that information or not you but
a super computer some super mind some
laplacian Demon could from the initial
conditions and the laws deduce
everything that's going to happen that's
world one
um world two the initial conditions and
the laws underdetermine what's going to
happen in the future but they do it in a
probabilistic way it's some kind of
stochastic situation
um God is trying to build those two
worlds
do you think there's any ingredient that
God would have to put in
to
the deterministic world or the
indeterministic world to make it
indeterministic or make it deterministic
I guess what I'm trying to say is that
it to the extent that eternalism makes
sense
um
the there's no such thing as an
indeterministic world if I allow for
super smart pan temporal beings who can
tell me exactly what will happen in the
future but is it isn't there just a
totally so like
in one situation the initial conditions
and the laws
fix what happens in another situation
the initial conditions and the laws
don't fix what happens isn't that a
non-epistemic
difference maybe there's no knowers in
these worlds at all right I think that I
guess one way of saying what I'm trying
to say is that I would count the
complete future history of the universe
as a candidate law of physics
not a very useful one but if that were
somehow made accessible to me I mean in
practice It Isn't So that's fine in
practice we we deal with probabilities
all the time I'm a complete subjectivist
about probability I think the
probability is always about what we know
and so if you tell me someone out there
could in principle have a complete list
of everything that happens in the future
and if I could get a hold of that that
would count to me as a deterministic law
can I ask you one more question about
this of course
so one of the things that sort of
encoded into the principle of sufficient
reason
um is a kind of symmetry between
explanation and a certain sort of
prediction
so
um
according to the principles of visual
reason what it is to be in a position to
sort of fully explain something is to be
able to give reasons that make
epistemically sufficient concluding that
sort of p is going to happen or whatever
yeah
um on the kind of
picture that you're alluding to where we
get determinism because we get the sort
of full world histories
um do you think there's an explanatory
asymmetry between the say laws that are
determined by partial World histories
versus so for just to go back to our
um coin flip case uh you've seen the
coin land heads before you travel back
in time that gives you great evidence of
the queen lands heads yeah
but presumably it doesn't play any role
in explaining why the coin lands heads
and in general these sort of
eternalistic facts these facts about the
future
they're going to give us great
predictive evidence about what's going
to happen
um what do you feel about their
explanatory
power or
well I think that there absolutely is a
distinction between the case where
the information I need to have now in
order to predict the future with 100
Fidelity is
pretty simple right is the current state
of the universe plus some dynamical laws
versus the case where someone just needs
to literally tell me what happens in the
future and so maybe that distinction
maps on to the existence of explanations
but I think that's up to us I don't
think explanations are spooky things out
there in the world either I think that
the existence of a possible
compact statement of regularity is very
very useful whatever you want to call it
when you think of
uh uh say I have two empirical theories
that are observationally equivalent
um I don't know how observationally
equivalent to make them maybe they're
just observational equivalent about a
particular outcome but let's but let's
say they're at least observationally
equivalent for everything that actually
happens
uh but their contents are different
maybe they uh maybe they're you know
different formulations of Newtonian
mechanics or something yeah
um make the same predictions do you
think there could be two theories that
make the same predictions but one is a
better explanatory story than another or
one is genuinely explaining
whereas the other one is just making
predictions but not genuinely explained
I think that if the two Theory this is a
great question and I think I'm actually
going to extend it in just a second but
the to actually answer it I think that
if the two theories make literally the
same predictions like there's literally
a mathematical equivalence between them
like you know hamiltonian versions of
classical mechanics versus lagrangian
versus of classical mechanics then I
think that they literally are the same
Theory I think that there's no sense in
which one is the right one what one
provides better explanations or anything
like that they're equivalent
but I think the reason why we're tempted
to think that one is better explanation
than the other is because we don't know
what the final laws are and thinking in
terms of one formulation of the of the
laws might lead us naturally to extend
them in certain ways right like give us
ideas about what happens next what a
better formulation of it is and starting
from a hamiltonian versus lagrangian
might take us down very different
hypothetical roads right so in practice
since we don't know the laws there could
be a big difference between different
mathematically but morally
mathematically equivalent but morally in
equivalent ways of thinking
and so any type two theories are
mathematically equivalent the whether or
not one is true or the other is false
those those mean the same thing for one
Theory to be true implies the same thing
about the world then for the other
Theory to be true if they're
observational equivalent that's right if
they're and if they're observationally
filled in and actually true I mean yeah
yeah yeah oh sorry
if they're observational equivalent and
actually I was wondering if there could
be a case where they are observationally
equivalent one was true
uh one was false but I mean I mean I
mean true in the sense that we're not
gonna tomorrow do an experiment that
overthrows both of them yes right they
really are their observations are
they're empirically adequate
they're the same Theory to me and I
think that uh I have a lot like a lot of
my my project I have a project that's so
sweet
um is to start from like the most basic
formulation that I can imagine of the
fundamental laws of physics and recover
the Manifest image from it right and you
know say okay this is why we have tables
and chairs and and things like that and
what almost everyone does physicists and
philosophers to me is that they cheat
they they know what the Manifest image
looks like so they're just gonna burden
their ontology with ideas about laws of
physics and space and and you know what
have you and I really want to
get those as effective emergent higher
level approximate things and figure out
why those are nevertheless useful to us
that's very interesting
is that your way of saying that it's
completely nuts no no no no I the thing
I'm particularly interested in is this
idea that
um
that something like observational
equivalence implies equivalence all the
way through or something that there
couldn't be sort of two theories that
give us different claims about what the
unobservable world is like uh but make
the same claims about what the
observable world is like so that they're
sort of the truth of the theories is
underdetermined by it's not just
undetermined by the evidence we actually
have but it's underdetermined by all the
evidence we could possibly obtain
um because they sort of agree about the
observable world but disagree about the
unobservable world well no I do I mean
that's what I was gesturing at badly
when I said that if both theories are
true I mean in the case of hamiltonian
mechanics versus lagrangian mechanics
you can literally start from the
equations of one and derive the
equations of the other so I think that
it is impossible to imagine a case where
tomorrow we will do an experiment that
says one is right and the other one's
right for sure yeah for sure so that
that's what I have in mind you know
different theories even in principle
make all the same predictions any deeper
fact about the world that would make you
say ah one of these formulations is sort
of getting the structure of reality
better than the other formulation or
something
not if both you know not unless there
was some experiment we could do which
was compatible with one but not the
other yeah
um I do think like I said there's
different different theories can lead
you to extend them in different ways so
I think it's very important to think
about them but if they're if I can truly
do a mathematical equivalence let me
give it let me give it one very down to
earth example I know it's late in the
podcast so we're down to the hardcore
listeners now so they're willing to to
go down roads further than the beginners
that you know the casuals who are just
listening for the first 10 minutes
um you know if you have a box of gas
with 10 to the 23 particles in it and
you want to say okay the laws of physics
are you know that for each particle they
obey Newton's laws and they bump into
each other uh and so where the system
lives the conventional thing to say is
is in three-dimensional space or maybe
you know
um six-dimensional phase space and
there's many many points the system is a
set of 10 to the 23 points in a
six-dimensional phase space or a
three-dimensional space okay
alternatively it's one point in a giant
six times ten to the 23 dimensional
phase space right and those are
mathematically equivalent but almost
everyone says yeah but come on it
clearly lives in space lives in
three-dimensional space right like
that's just a mathematical trick you're
doing I want to say nope it's equally
real it's equally good there's no
improvement of one over the other the
reason why you think there's an
improvement is because you often have
incomplete information
and one of these ways of talking
generalizes better to the case of
incomplete information right and the
other one doesn't so to me the reason
why you want to privilege one equivalent
Theory over another one is not because
of the theories themselves but how they
fit nicely into a bigger framework
um great
um
let me just go you know
flossy intro philosophy yeah on you do
you ever think about stuff like um
like whether or not we're living in a
simulation or whether or not we're like
living in a dream or the Matrix or
something like that I mean one way of
thinking about this skeptical scenarios
is that they're trying to describe
uh a way things could be observationally
equivalent for us
um but the
underpinions of reality be radically
different so I don't know maybe I'm just
a brain in a vet it seems to me like
there's a television in fact all right
what is this called a computer monitor
in front of me
um but really what's going on is that
like some scientist is poking my brain
in some kind of science fiction story
um now I feel like what you're gonna say
pretty quickly is that there's like
possible experiments that could be
conducted in these scenarios to
distinguish the brain and the vat case
from The Real World case is that what
you're gonna say no not necessarily I
mean that's certainly true right or I
mean at least it's plausibly true but
I'm willing to consider the thought
experiment where there aren't any
experiments we could do what I what I
would ask is uh which is more
explanatory so I'm certainly open to the
possibility that I am a brain into that
or I am in a simulation or whatever
um but if my best theory of the universe
is here are the laws of physics here are
the initial conditions and I'm brain in
a vat versus you're the laws of physics
here are the initial conditions and both
of those theories make exactly the same
predictions and statements Etc the I'm
not going to waste time thinking that
I'm a brain an event or living in a
simulation or whatever I mean maybe
there's some anthropic reason or
something like that but uh yeah until so
I would say that until we do some
experiment or have some insight that is
better explained by this extra little
bit of metaphysical baggage I'm not
going to pay too much attention to it
good so just
flagging some things so we've got at
least three ideas in the conversation
one sort of idea is uh you know if the
theories are observationally equivalent
uh do we give a damn which theory is
true should I worry about it should I
spend time sort of agonizing about it
another question is uh how would we know
if they're observationally equivalent
could we ever get evidence for one
Theory over the other and you said
something really interesting you said
that you thought one Theory we might
pick one Theory over the other because
it was more explanatory than the other
um and then the third thing is that well
uh if their observation the equivalent
they they don't say anything different
across the board so what it would be for
one of the theories to be true what the
world would be like if one of the
theories is true it's just the same as
what the world would be like if the
observationally equivalent theory was
true and be and those are sort of three
different Notions and the strongest kind
of thing to think is what the world
would be like if the brain of the vat
scenario is true and our regular
hypothesis is true there's no important
difference between what those theories
are saying about the world because they
make the same observational predictions
that seems like a very strong thing to
think then there's a kind of much the
sort of weakest thing to think is like
who cares these are stupid questions we
shouldn't worry about these like very
high fluent questions and it's the
middle ground that I'm particularly
interested in So when you say
oh well one of these theories would be
explanatory and the other Theory
wouldn't be even though they are
observationally equivalent do you have
any idea about how you would tell
which theory was the better explanation
or like what what comes to your mind
when you say things like oh we could
look see which was more explanatory yeah
I think that we had to be a little bit
more clear about observational
equivalents I mean in the case of
hamiltonian mechanics versus LaGrange
mechanics they're not just
observationally equivalent they are
mathematically equivalent to each other
right the brain in a vat or simulation
is a little bit different because
they're even if I by stipulation cannot
notice any difference in principle there
absolutely are observational differences
I could get a picture of the brain in a
vat you know in the evil scientist
laboratory or whatever
um but I mean there's a much more down
to earth example of exactly this which
is the cosmological Multiverse right
where you say okay we have observational
access to a finite amount of space-time
and what happens past that and if you if
you put on the table two options one is
that it's just more of the same forever
and ever and ever and the other is no no
in different regions very very far away
conditions are highly different
observationally to us in the real world
those are absolutely equivalent
in principle if you imagine that we have
access to Regions that are further than
we can possibly see then they're not and
I think that there are explanatory
differences between them because in the
single Universe case if you have a
number like the cosmological constant
you have to say well that's it it I need
to come up with an explanation for this
number maybe the explanation is we're
just lucky but I need to figure out why
my best understanding was it was that
whereas in the Multiverse example there
I can't come up with a single
explanation for why that number is what
it is because it's different numbers in
different parts of the universe and I
have a completely different explanatory
framework involving anthropics and
selection and things like that so I do
think that that's the sense in which
there's different explanatory
capabilities for different theories that
have exactly the same observable
consequences
yeah that's all totally reasonable can I
try one more on you and then I will give
up this Pro I don't even know what the
project is
um are the
here are two different possibilities
uh so when I clap you hear that sat you
see my hands go together and then you
hear that sound
um hypothesis one
um there's a correlation between
clapping my hands and that sound but
there's no causal relationship so
throughout all time uh when I clap my
hands it'll make that sound that's true
for other people's hands too uh it's
just a huge coincidence there's no
causal relationship between those two
things that's hypothesis one hypothesis
two uh there is a causal relationship
between those two things my hands going
together cause that sound
um because the first hypothesis sort of
has it built in that its observational
stuff is going to be just like the
second hypothesis so you're never going
to find a case where somebody claps
their hands and doesn't make the sound
um I'm wondering whether you think like
oh these are like two different live
possibilities or whether you think eh
there's not much to there's not much
different between these two classes well
we haven't talked about in this podcast
but we I've mentioned before the human
anti-human distinction and it was Barry
lower who was a previous guest who years
ago first told me I should really care
about this distinction and my result my
answer was no I don't I don't need to
care about this distinction at all but
he has changed my mind about it now I
realize that I should and the reason why
I should uh is because I think it
changes how we think about other
possible worlds and counterfactuals
right whether the laws of physics have
oomph and existence and spookiness all
by themselves versus if they're just a
convenient some summary of things but
anyway and you and you can give us your
opinion about that distinction if you
want but for the hand clapping I would
say at the level of
fundamental physics as we currently
understand it
I just don't want to talk a language of
causes and effects at all I do want to
just talk a language of correlations
patterns differential equations what
have you I think that the language of
causes and effects becomes relevant in
the macroscopic world where we have
incomplete information
and we have an arrow of time and then
we're saying well given the way that the
Universe evolves macroscopically every
time you clap your hands you hear a
noise I think that's a perfectly fair
thing to attach the words cause and
effect to the the uh the it's an
emergent higher level thing that when
you clap your hands you hear it a noise
yeah see I figured you were going to say
the difference between the correlation
case and the causation case is that in
the causation case if you were to clap
your hands an additional time then it
would make the noise and in the
correlation case
we don't have a strong reason to think
that if you were to clap your hands an
additional number of times it would have
made the noise
um so I wondered if like this was part
of your counterfactual
Your Love of counterfection well I think
I can maybe I can be a human and still
think that there are laws of physics
right so I I do think that the existence
of the noise after the clap does follow
from the Persistence of these patterns
over time so I I still would predict
that every time you clap your hands or
even though I don't want to talk about
it at the fundamental laws of physics
way as a cause effect relation I
shouldn't think I can make the
prediction
you're not a clapping sounds skeptic I
am not
and I don't know so are you Humane or
anti-humine where do you fall there we
didn't get a chance to talk about that
um what is the right name um
the right answer is the anti-humans are
right I mean it depends on what you're
into if you're
if you're into uh
there's a lot of bad things about being
a human a lot of normal things that
people think that you can't say and I
think it would be really nice to say
those things on the other hand the
anti-human theory is always very sort of
sketchy I mean not always there are
people who are anti-humans and they will
not like it if I say their theories are
sketchy but the the basic cost of
anti-humanism is you have to say what it
is that you're positing what the hell
you're talking about that's very hard to
do
um I think pursuing that project is sort
of more interesting than pursuing the
human project or something I have
aesthetic reasons for wanting to be an
animal I think that's okay I have
aesthetic reasons for wanting to be
human I think that the the course of
physics are just spooky Essences that I
want to get rid of I want to scrub all
the spookiness from my
my ontology I want my ultimate ontology
at the end of the day to be a single
point in the high dimensional space of
all important to be some equations
that's the world I want to laugh yeah
that is the saddest
thing I remember
and that is the perfect place to end the
podcast thank you very much Katie for
telling me the sadness that I have to
wake up to or not go to sleep with every
time I think about it and thank you very
much for being such a good guest on the
podcast
um thanks this was really really fun uh
you're you you should do something that
having to do with philosophy Sean you're
good at it all right someday you never
know in the future what would the what
would the magical being say about that
[Music]